c'est dans ce climat que le premier
ministre répondant aux questions
d'emmanuel de la taille et jean marie
cavada a précisé tout à l'heure l'esprit
dans lequel il va commencer la semaine
prochaine son dialogue avec tous les
partenaires sociaux écoutez je crois que
la france
est un pays de société libérale et une
société pluraliste dans une telle
société
il faut qu'existe un dialogue social un
dialogue entre les partenaires sociaux
un dialogue entre les partenaires
sociaux et le gouvernement
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
recevrai pendant toute la semaine
prochaine toutes les organisations
professionnelles
je voudrais à ce sujet a indiqué que si
je suis partisan du dialogue
l'estiment qui ne jouant pas qu'il y ait
une conclusion des responsables
les organisations professionnelles sont
chargés de les fondre de façon très
légitime d'ailleurs les intérêts de leur
mandat l'état lui est en charge de
l'intérêt général
et après une information
après une discussion
loyal est clair le gouvernement arrêtera
la politique économique et financière
qui permettra de lutter contre
l'inflation cette politique j'espère
qu'elle sera une politique de clarté et
de justice vous imposez ministre avant
de recevoir parmi les partenaires
sociaux notamment les syndicats la
semaine prochaine on a déjà depuis la
mi- départ la parole de par la bouche de
mes yeux c'est guy pour la cgt incertain
avant goût de ce que peut être cette
conversation sept centrales syndicales
appellent à une sorte de mobilisation
générale nous verrons ce que ça donnera
avec les autres partenaires syndicaux
quelle est votre opinion à ce sujet et
comment réagissez vous à ce commentaire
mon opinion je les exprime de la maine
or que vous venez d'exprimer la vôtre
nous verrons bien et en ce qui concerne
l'impôt sécheresse est ce que vous
maintenez le principe de cet impôt est
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas essayé de
l'élargir dans un plan d'ensemble de
façon à ce que les agriculteurs n'ai pas
l'impression qu'on va braquer les
salariés contre oui
les agriculteurs ont été frappés par une
calamité nationale
normale par conséquent qu'il y est un
effort de solidarité nationale à leur
égard je vous rappelle que c'est au mois
de juin dernier que le président de la
république a dit que le revenu des
agriculteurs pour
1976 ne devrait pas être inférieur à
celui et qu'ils avaient obtenu en 1975
au mois d'août le 25 août le
gouvernement a décidé décède à valoir
sur les aides définitives qui seront
accordés après le conseil des ministres
du 29 septembre
il est nécessaire en effet d'attendre
qu'un bilan soit dressé et à partir de
là nous fixerons le montant et la
répartition de l'effort définitif mais
la france est dans une situation
inflationniste
par conséquent l'effort de solidarité
nationale doit être effectué dans des
conditions qui
n'aggrave pas la situation des finances
publiques
il est donc normal que l'on ait recours
à l'impôt je sais que certains
préconisent un recours à l'emprunt j'ai
le sentiment que c'est une forme assez
subtil d'égoïsme ça veut dire qu'il n'y
aura pas de recours à l'emprunt il n'y
aura pas de recours à l'emprunt pour une
raison très simple c'est que recourir à
l'emprunt signifie que l'on transférait
sur les générations futures
la charge de l'effort national qui doit
être accompli et je voudrais ajouter si
vous permettez et sur un point et une
réponse à la question posée par monsieur
de la taille
le collectif budgétaire qui interviendra
le 29 septembre
doit assurer l'équilibré des finances
publiques et les aides qui seront
accordées aux agriculteurs
seront un élément seulement de l'effort
qui doit être accompli pour que nos
finances publiques restent équilibrés ce
qui veut dire monsieur par les ministres
éventuellement c'est impôts dont il
reste à définir la hauteur la gamme
c'est un peu pourrait servir non
seulement à la solidarité sécheresse
mais par exemple d'autres calamités qui
souffrirait vous bien équilibrer le
budget mais vous savez le jus que le
décret d'avant ce qui a été signé il ya
quelques jours et vise non seulement les
aides apportées aux agriculteurs mais
également les frais qui sont liées à
aux conséquences de l'éruption du volcan
de la soufrière d'entrée conditions de
scène premier ministre qu'est ce qu'elle
voulait dire le ministre l'agriculture
monsieur bonnet hier en parlant d' impôt
sur les personnes morales pourrait-il
s'agir par exemple d'un impôt sur le
capital
je ne crois pas qu'il faille pour le
moment
par les diverses méthodes
pour la raison bien simple que nous ne
connaissons pas le montant
définitif de l'aide apportée
et le gouvernement n'a pas délibéré des
conditions dans lesquelles le recours à
l'impôt s'effectuerait
je considère par conséquent que tout ce
qui peut être dit à l'heure actuelle
ne repose pas sur qu une information
fondée
j'ai le premier ministre vous avez fait
un démarrage tambour battant ce séguy à
parly 2 euros est ce que vous pensez pas
qu l'attend maintenant des mesures
jouent contre eux le climat d'agitation
avant les mesures un show de la terre si
j'étais zorro
peut-être suis-je plutôt bernardo je
suis un grand amateur des films de zorro
en excuses
on dit que le capital de confiance dont
je dispose est à cet égard je voudrais
remercier des françaises et les français
qui m'ont écrit il ne me connaissait pas
mais qui nous écrit des lettres fort
encourageante
ceci dit
il n'y a pas le feu dans la maison
la politique contre l'inflation a déjà
été entreprise elle doit être poursuivie
et elle doit être amplifiée et il n'y a
aucune raison de draps de dramatiser la
situation actuelle la situation est
préoccupante je ne veux pas dire qu'il
faille considérer avec une certaine
série et les problèmes que nous aurons à
résoudre à la fin de cette année et l'an
prochain
mais néanmoins il faut éviter toute
précipitation
de surcroît
une politique économique et financière
fut-elle élaboré par le premier ministre
qui assume en même temps les fonctions
de ministre de l'économie et des
finances n'est pas l'oeuvre d'un seul
homme elle est l'oeuvre d'un
gouvernement par conséquent il est
normal que le gouvernement délibère et
là était entendu que la délibération
aura lieu le 22 septembre
de telle sorte que les mesures qui
interviendront dans la loi de finances
pour
1977 soit présenté au parlement à ce
moment enfin
j'ai souhaité avant d'arrêter les
mesures je proposerai au gouvernement
recevoir les organisations syndicales
que n'aurait-on pas dit si j'avais fait
sortir des mesures comme un lapin d'un
chapeau
et si je ne mettais pas entouré d'avis
de suggestions et de conseil ce que je
voudrais dire aux françaises et aux
français c'est que je crois que la
politique du gouvernement doit être
conduite en dehors de toute agitation le
premier ministre dans un certain nombre
de démocraties anglo saxon quand il ya
crise ou situation d'austérité grave on
va le chef du gouvernement consulter ou
en tout cas entendre les chefs de
l'opposition est ce que vous seriez prêt
à adopter la même procédure
je crois que depuis de nombreux mois
déjà
le président de la république a dit
qu'il était tout prêt à recevoir les
chefs de l'opposition
en ce qui me concerne ma porte est
ouverte
le point de formuler une invitation
je n'ai pas formulé d'invitation ceux
qui désirent me voir sont toujours sûr
que je m'arrangerai pour les rencontrer